some it's a little dark backstage and I
just said to a man what's on next and he
said unfortunately Niven I I rather like
that it has a certain Damon Runyon
flavor there's Harry the horse
nicely-nicely Johnson and unfortunately
Niven
so I'm unfortunately Niven and I am your
Mouse of ceremonies for the next chunk
of the show I have here instructions for
the masters of ceremonies as compiled by
mr. garibaldi is our headmaster he says
I quote over 100 million people will see
this show therefore please one introduce
yourself well I've done that that's done
to try to smile and look Pleasant haha
done that relax relax
in front of 100 million people the
Headmaster's blown his court for be
informal
the fifth one be brief this I can handle
now to present the award for the best
performance by an actress best
performance by an actress in a
supporting role we have two stars with
much in common each of them made a
memorable first screen appearance and
each of them has a memorable first name
Shelley Winters and red buttons
who's your tailor I'd like to thank
everyone for helping me win the Oscar
for the best performance no no no no red
that was the speech you made last year
when you got one now this year you give
one out no wonder it feels different the
nominees are
Peggy Cass for Auntie Mame and miss
Wendy Hiller for separate tables
Martha hire for some came running
Maureen Stapleton Lonelyhearts
Cara Williams the Defiant ones and the
winner is wendy hiller in separate
tables
accepting the award for miss wendy
hiller is mr. harold Hecht
it's a great honor to be able to accept
this great award for wendy hiller a
great actress thank you